anyone I've ever made this grilled  cheese sandwich for says it's the best  one they've ever had in their life so  I'm going to teach you my secrets first  I start with some mayonnaise cheddar and  herbs and mix it up before slicing my  sourdough bread nice and thick I butter  it on both sides and start layering my  cheeses but here's the secret that Mayo  mixture you're gonna put it right in the  middle of your grilled cheese sear it on  both sides until your cheese is nice and  melted and there you have it you're  gonna enjoy your sandwich and then  you're gonna thank me for the best  grilled cheese recipe ever try it out  and let me know what you think